we are seeing more and more studies
pointing out that omicron is infecting
the upper part of the body unlike other
ones the lung who has been causing
severe pneumonia it can be a good news
but we really require more studies to
prove that
we had a good number of studies coming
up proving again what we had from south
africa that the vaccine still protect
new agnes hospitalization and severe
disease and death and that's what things
were designed the challenge has not been
the vaccine but the vaccination and
reaching those vulnerable populations
whenever omnicross is introduced it will
be a matter of weeks before it becomes
the dominant so the number has been
fluctuated because of the availability
of the data and the lag
uh
just to give you an example in the u.s
the report initially 70 percent when all
the data came back it went to 57 so
there will be a fluctuation with the
christmas backlog with the new year i
think we'll have a better idea of the
proportion in the coming
days i was given an example that the
south africa is an outlier that we
shouldn't base our information based on
as a younger population the university
student population moving together
and
and then the population disappears in
december everyone the country shut down
like in western europe in august or
except vegas only in france it's very
hard everyone goes in the hallway so
december for south africa is where
everyone goes out on hallway so the
epidynamics
will be different
so my point of new york and
london is where they hit very hard now
with omicron we see the underground how
it is going on we can
build some scenarios but the main point
again and again is how much
your population have not been vaccinated
there's a lot of decisions to be met and
the main support we require is a global
coordinator rather than the commercial
industry growing of the industry alone
going ahead but a well coordinated based
on the experience we had with the flu